[Music]
all right we are live on YouTube people
I have just returned from touring with
Jordan Peterson I went directly to Joe
Rogan and now we're gonna do a show
joining me today is neuroscientist
best-selling author and mysterious man
of Internet controversy Sam Harris
welcome back to the Reuben thank you
thank you how is that for any tro for
you mysterious man of internet if it
works as well as anything else in my bio
hat you seem to be somebody that wants
inner peace and yet constantly involved
in these endless i do enough to screw
that up it seems for reasons that i
can't figure out but is that a
scientific test for you possibly well
you know i've just i don't think we've
talked about this but i've pulled back
from social media to a big degree yeah
that is a variable that i mean i
obviously I'd heard that advertised to
me as a problem and yeah I had thought
about it and the abstract is a problem I
know you've gone you know off the grid
for a month or something but just I mean
I I've cut down
I was never using Facebook as anything
other than a publishing channel I never
got into comments on Facebook but I got
hooked by Twitter as you know and I'm
probably spending five minutes a day on
Twitter at most I'm just it's just a
surgical strike on Twitter just put
something out see what's there read a
couple article you know just find links
to articles that interest me so I mean
it's still a way of getting news but to
not to fundamentally not only not engage
but not even know what's going on on
Twitter has been a total reset of my
brain I mean it's it's a it's been
amazingly toxic in a way that I never
appreciated so yeah so I think my
audience knows my feelings on this that
it yeah it's endlessly toxic yet at some
level it's helped to connect all of us I
mean we originally connected through
Twitter these things kind of morph and
changing moments where they're much
worse and then suddenly they're much
better they also help you know help
start revolutions in the Middle East so
it's like not all evil but are you
afraid a little bit of getting
disconnected oh yeah they're like if you
know that you'll miss some of the
zeitgeist well I'm definitely missing
stuff
yeah and I'm I'm still trying to use it
strategically so I'm trying to use it in
precise
the way you just described with there
trying to get connected with people I've
reached out to somebody who's this woman
diakon who just did a documentary I want
to get her on the podcast I tweeted at
her I haven't spent enough time looking
to see if she's even noticed so it's
like I'm not totally paying attention
but the benefit has been just immense
because they I just realized I that is a
kind of it's a kind of hallucination
machine where you begin to think you
need to pay attention to certain voices
that in the real world you would never
see and they and I'm agnostic as to
whether or not these voices are in fact
consequential and you could sort of lose
sight of how your reputation is
unraveling online and you know just
start getting phone calls from friends
saying sorry that's happening to you
which i think is you know that's
happened to some people but yeah you
know for in my experience I maybe
there's some exception to this but
virtually all of my kind of substantial
controversial engagements on Twitter
where I've noticed somebody go after me
and then I've responded and then I
either I've done a podcast in respond
whatever that whatever that the however
that's propagated in my life
the net result has always been like
you're getting back to zero if you're
lucky yeah right it's like the whole
thing is a confection of having been on
social media in the first place and
you're lucky to get back to zero and I
mean the truth is someone like you movie
can name the you know the none of these
people exist in the real world I know
like like I mean they're not it's a you
know and I would never see them just
read in the New York Times for the most
part I certainly never see them in my
life and now it's just it's very strange
to feel like because someone had said
something about you on social media or
you know lied about you or spread an
article that was terrible about you
whatever it is that you then have to
somehow engage and and people you know
right like you know who was it
most recently Robert Wright just wrote
this you know idiotic Wired piece about
me right it's just like there's there's
not a single sentence in the piece that
needs to be responded to yeah I get
inundated with by people think well
listen you really got to respond
this is this is you know interesting and
substantial and it's nothing of the kind
it's like it's his attempt at clickbait
it's his attempt to provoke a some kind
of controversy between us on one of our
podcasts he reached out to me so I just
wrote this about you you know I hope
you'll come on my podcast or I'll come
on yours to talk about fishing yeah and
it's just it's a completely disingenuous
and insubstantial thing and yet paying
attention it is a kind of meditation
it's like it's you've become what you
meditate on yeah become what you pay
attention to and so checking Twitter 30
times a day or whatever I was doing just
built a new mind for me which I you know
I know I'm very happy to get rid of so
yeah I don't know I don't know that I'll
ever get totally off it because for the
reasons you suggest but I mean I I've
cut it down literally by 95 percent yeah
so I saw the interview you did with that
CBS News about a week or two ago and you
talked about how it's kind of making us
all crazy oh no that was an Australian
that was was that Australia's ABC in
Australia yeah so I saw that and you
said something about how it's kind of
making us all crazy and it was making me
think to your point just now that it
seems like we're almost living in two
worlds at the same time right now like
if you walk around staring in that thing
like I'm travelling a lot now so if I'm
like at the airport like I'm looking at
this thing you almost get disconnected
from the actual physical loop oh yeah
you totally do you start ending up in
some alternate world and to me that's a
little bit sort of where we're gonna end
up with with AI with all of these
they're all gonna kind of collide into
one thing that we're gonna end up in the
matrix or something like that yeah well
and you can be buried on your phone
obviously without being buried on social
media so you know I have taken it off my
phone which is a huge the kind of
gatekeeping function but what do you
know about how it changes our perception
of time because that that's actually
where I was gonna start with you because
we just figured out so the last time you
were on the show was July of 2016
basically two years ago which is crazy
and it sort of seems like yesterday to
me and yet it also seems like like 18
lifetimes ago and I think that maybe has
something to do with social media
changing the way we perceive time or so
think well I don't know I don't think
it's just social media I think it's just
I mean it's everything everything is
conspiring to make time go faster it's
you're getting older just the the the
the increase in novelty and just change
its that we have we're seen changes in
culture and technology that are clearly
accelerating so the world is different
over the course of more different over
the course of the year then it's ever
been I think that's that's objectively
true yeah but also yours getting older
so that every year is you know that much
less a piece of your the life you've
lived you know if you're if you're 40
you know at the next year's is 140th of
the time you've been around and then you
know that becomes 150th and so it's
subjectively shorter and yeah I'm a year
for me is like four months long now and
just yeah they just blast by so there
are a couple things I want to hit on
here we'll do a little bit of politics
and but I do want to talk about
consciousness and I want to talk about
your upcoming talks with Peterson and
obviously I've gotten to know his my
pretty well at this point inside
information that I should have at this
point I might I might be able to offer
you a little something and I think maybe
we can set the table for how many events
you do anything we're doing for we're
for the only of four we've spoken about
others but I think four is certainly
enough to see whether we can we can do
this so the funny thing it might be
three too many it might be for too many
you'll find out but the funny thing is
that I didn't know until I mentioned to
him last night when we were in Atlanta I
said oh you know I have Sam on tomorrow
is there anything on your mind that I
could bring up that'll sort of set the
table for this whole thing I didn't
realize that you guys have actually
never met in person know which having
listened to the two podcasts we have you
know you did on computer or on skype or
whatever that that podcast thing you
used that's kind of crazy that you guys
haven't actually sat there and just you
know looked in his eyes and not on this
does that feel weird to you that you're
gonna do all this publicly in that way
no well I've done a bunch of events with
people I've never met you know where
it's a podcast guest or you know some
what I'm sharing the stage with for the
first time and so I've actually I've I
know him better than several the people
I've recently done live events with
I've spoken him on the phone once and
we've done this to podcast so yeah but
yeah no it's it's obviously not optimal
to be having these conversations well it
selects for different things I think
there are people I think it's I think
Terry Gross of fresh air will never do
anything face-to-face I think she does
all of her interviews in even if you're
in Philadelphia I could could be behind
I think she just likes this or the
purity of the pure audio and it could
because the product is audio there's no
video component to it and I understand
that in the sense that if you're having
like it so so if we were just doing an
audio podcast now I mean now as a just a
pure audio podcaster I'm sensitive to
this you and I are having an experience
now we're looking at each other we have
various cues we know we have a sense of
how the conversations going yeah and
which can be misleading you because if
the final product is just audio you can
think there's stuff coming through which
isn't coming through and so when you
don't have any of those any of that
information and you just got the other
person's voice on the line you have a
very clear sense of what you're getting
and if you're not getting what you want
to be getting then you modify what
you're doing in some on some level so
yeah so yeah it's working for me but I
think it's as far as establishing
rapport with someone it's definitely not
ideal so and we've had moments where we
we could have used more rapport probably
yeah all right let's shelve the rest of
Peters head until after what what do you
make of this whole thing somehow the
conversations that we've all been having
often completely independently of each
other right I mean you haven't been here
for two years I've suddenly become like
the zeitgeist thing like you know Barry
Weiss wrote this intellectual dark web
article people think we have a card and
there's a clubhouse and the whole thing
as far as if there is I haven't been
invited right but that that whatever it
is we're all doing the conversations
you're having and I'm having and Rogen's
having and this whole crew of people
seem to be doing something that was very
needed at some level or another yeah
well I think we there's certainly a
diversity of opinion within this group
or
pseudo group about what's going on here
I mean we as you know we have not had a
meeting where we've agreed that you know
what about what this is yeah but is
anything we've had a quite half a
meeting where we disagreed on it yeah
and early that yeah and and did you see
Eric one signs video about just what
what this was and that and it's like so
a hundred percent of what he said on
that video was never anything that he
said to me or that you know it's like
this you know this is how he coined the
phrase in his own mind yeah why I just
brought him up onstage in Tempe at the
improv the night before and I think he
was high on comedy and just like I'm
gonna talk to people right right and so
I'm at da and everything he said very
interesting yeah and as you know I I
love Eric he's fantastic but here he
coined the phrase
on my podcast I think in on earlier
podcast but then it was reiterated in
this a live event we did with Ben
Shapiro right you mean that was odd cast
yeah and I no exaggeration I thought for
like 15 seconds about what I was going
to title the podcast it was just it was
just you know so it was a it was it has
always been tongue-in-cheek and if a
fairly superficial analogy for me and
but it but an interesting one in the
sense that there is the analogy to the
dark web is appropriate in that insofar
as there's this area where a lot is
going on that the mainstream media in
this case is basically unaware of I mean
then obviously there's many people in
the mainstream media and people who
consume the mainstream media where their
lists also listening to my podcast or
Rogen's or watching you so they you know
many people know we exist but people are
have been very slow to appreciate just
how big the audience is I mean Rogen's
audience is just north of you know and
you know but our audiences are absurd
compared to what's happening on you know
CNN for instance but you know I mean
Rogen's audience is like it's like every
episode is the finale of the Game of
Thrones right yeah it's just it's
completely and saying no one knows this
right like he occasionally brags about
how big his audiences but it's my sense
is that the people the New York Times
aren't aware
or people even CNN aren't aware that
they're in competition with me just to
take CNN is the most relevant comment if
you get invited to go on Anderson
Cooper's show tonight and give an
interview you're gonna get six minutes
you know the best-case 12 minutes to try
to make sense and try to not embarrass
yourself within a within a frame that is
really rigid it's not me the time
pressure alone modifies just what kind
of conversation I don't have there and
in primetime you're gonna go out to a
million people at best with Anderson
Cooper and how many are actually
watching the television to me the
televisions on in all sorts of rotations
that nobody's even watching yeah yeah so
maybe you know I count my audience it's
something like a million people and as
hard as you know to get great podcast
metrics but Joe's is probably 10 times
that per episode if not more so I mean
you're talking it so and and in those
cases you're talking about two and three
hour conversations that people are
actually listening to and forget about
what it's like to be the host on a show
like that the the opportunity for
someone else to come on and have a
conversation and and make sense and
correct themselves and go through the
whole warp and woof of a genuine
conversation that isn't unnaturally
bounded by a time limit of I mean I
noticed the difference between a
hour-long radio conversation that gets
ported to put a podcast where everyone
just knew clearly this they had to bring
this in at an hour like even that
defines the conversation and so I think
people are very slow to wake up to how
those two things like a big audience
with an unlimited time for a
conversation changes and also just
different you know incentives with
respect to funding of these things
because you know there's no one no one's
gonna fire Joe Rogan yeah Sam Harris I
gotta fire Cyrus yeah no not well well I
fired my my Twitter director yeah but
it's and so that that part of the
analogy is interesting because it's
allowing for a very different style of
airing ideas and and the substance is
chain
you know and so and I think people value
it I mean you you you know when you're
listening to one of our podcasts that
you're getting a a much less paranoid
much less circumspect much more
open-ended sir a search for sanity and
and and you know got kind of convergence
between you know dudes in some cases
radically different opinions yeah then
you're getting in other media I like
that open-ended search for sanity
because I think we've all tried to
figure out what are the commonalities
here because right we've got I mean you
and been basically disagree on every not
only pretty much every political
position not not everyone but 90% of the
political stuff you and ben shapiro but
of course also the existential stuff and
religion and all that stuff and yet you
guys are basically allies in that you're
defending the ability to have that
disagreement that seems to me to be the
thing that we're all doing like we here
we respect our audiences but more than
that we're respecting the ability for
people to sit here and disagree about
things that we have a couple political
disagreements that i want to get into a
little bit but to me those disagreements
aren't even that important as long as
we're defending the ability to think in
question and and i think that's what
we've all sort of done even though we
all came at it from very different
places yeah and then the master variable
for me is a good-faith disagreement so
it's like we're like I'm actually
concerned to get your position right
yeah and again some of this does I think
boil down to not having a time limit to
it's like I can take the time it doesn't
matter if we like what you know with
Peterson and I we can burn the first
hour
yes understanding one another right you
know or even blunder let me be the first
whole podcast then we do another podcast
would you so it's um it's well whereas
in any other format you just you don't
have the time to wonder whether or not
you're wrong about what you think the
other person just said and then you add
to that there's there's a kind of a
cynical point-scoring
that is just politically motivated that
you know is omnipresent and in
the usual context it you just have
people who are actually not having a
conversation it's just I'm gonna say the
thing that I think it's gonna make you
look bad
in the 45 seconds we have left yeah
that's the situation you're virtually
always in on television and and people
feel it and it's just like that no
wonder we're not making progress having
conversations about hard topics yeah
well I think we're making progress that
reminds me can you just quickly recap
you mentioned talking on your podcast a
couple weeks ago about how when when
Shapiro and Jordan were here that that
Jordan sort of misrepresented a position
your position sort of on truth and that
Ben then subsequently on Twitter
misrepresents I knew contacted both of
them and cleaned it all up and everyone
was good to go can you just recap that
real quick cuz I think sort of also
against to the heart of this that yes
they they both kind of admitted yeah we
one thing was half joke and whatever we
screwed up something but that we all
cleaned it up you guys all clean it up
and we're good and I think that's
important to reiterate yeah well that's
a point I've made that point on my
podcast to reiterate the difference
between the kinds of bad faith arguments
I'm getting predominantly from the left
and what I'm getting from the right and
I mean it was it was actually provoked
by a question on AMA I got which
actually was probably your hate mail I
you know I'm getting good some of some
of your hate mail weird that I forward
that yes yeah well it's like I'm getting
enough yeah
I'm sure you've gotten some of mine in
the past but someone was saying why are
you hanging out with all these
right-wing people and you seem to be
able to have a congenial conversation
with right-wingers like and then the
people on the list of right-wingers were
you and Rogan and and that any more
plausibly Ben Shapiro Jordan Peterson
and they married pro-choice against the
death penalty informing the prison
system blah blah blah right yeah and
wrote Rogan's Rogen's conservative bona
fides or don't don't go much further
than that yeah yeah but he hunts that's
that's what damn it I guess but so I you
know why can't you have the same kind of
good faith meeting of the minds with
someone on the left someone like Ezra
Klein or
any of your other antagonists on the
left Glenn Greenwald or Chris Hedges
and the difference has been in my
experience is that on the left
I am virtually always getting it just
like 90% of the time at least I'm
getting a an argument that I perceive to
be in bad faith where it's just that
they're you're the effort is to slime
you with a view you don't hold or take
the worst conceivable interpretation of
the view you hold and hold you to that
like I saw this thing you I heard this
thing you said I can interpret it to
make you look like a fascist maniac so
and so now the burden is on you for
forever to prove you're not a fascist
maniac oh yeah well I'm positive exactly
is there any chance that you think these
two forget the nit specifics of the
people but is there any chance you think
that these people are acting copy like
consciously good you know you mean like
that there that they really are just so
deeply misunderstanding that this is an
intention of evil in some key I mean I I
we could sort of do the post-mortem on
some of these but some I think are
genuinely confused some I think are
truly sinister in their level of
dishonesty yeah I don't personally I
think it's more of the latter but yeah
yeah I mean someone like jank yogur I
think he's he knows what he's doing and
he's yeah he's he knows he's misleading
his audience and you know it's just pure
politics and I would you know it's many
people I could name or fall into that
bin I would agree with you but so and
then then the thing that that is is
totally toxic is what is when it's
absolutely clear that someone has
misrepresented your view right so like
when Glenn Greenwald forwards to now
millions of people a segment of my
podcast that has been re-edited by some
Twitter troll to make me seem to be
saying the opposite of what I'm saying
in fact in the in context he he'll never
correct that error he'll him he'll never
apologize whereas I you know will
apologize instantly if I've
misrepresented him at one time I did
that you did it yeah and you actually
did do it yeah so this is a symmetric
warfare and so the point I made about
Peterson and Shapiro there is this
they both came on your show and in one
way or another totally misrepresented my
views missus Oh Peterson quite you know
comically and in my world said you know
the thing about Sam Harris is that he
doesn't understand that consciousness is
mysterious he doesn't he doesn't value
kind he went on this whole tirade about
Mike not getting just how mysterious and
profound and interesting consciousness
is whereas anyone who knows my stuff
knows that that's like the absolute
center of the center of the bullseye for
me you know ethically and intellectually
both as you know in terms of
neuroscience but philosophy of mind
moral philosophy I mean that's just you
know I say things like consciousness is
the one thing in this universe that
can't be an illusion right I mean we
could be in a simulation we could be
brains in vats we could be confused
about everything the one thing we can't
be confused about is that you know
consciousness is is our first you know
condition in each instant so so I just
emailed him and I said like dude you've
got me completely wrong on consciousness
you have to stop saying what you just
said on Reubens podcast because it makes
no sense and rather than and this again
if if I were going out to someone on the
left
you know the Ezra Klein's the the Reza
Aslan is the Jencks the Chris Hedges the
Glenn Greenwald's but I mean I've been
down this path so many times with these
guys made so people think this all plays
out in public and sometimes plays out in
private without every one of these guys
who's been a private communication which
is like listen this is objectively
mistaken right now never have gotten an
apology or a correction about anything
right what you get is basically [ __ ] you
this is what you really think right you
know you you know and but with Jordan
knows like sorry I guess I have to read
your book so I know what I'm talking
about yeah I think that's verbatim yeah
and by the way he has now yeah he told
me last night he's read all your books
now see that's ready I'm sure he's still
confused about something in those books
but we'll work that out
but and the same with Ben Ben was saying
something about I think it was free well
no great was right it was the joke about
the kid oh okay yeah yeah yeah so I I
had we at our event we got a question
from the audience which where someone
asked soso if free wills an illusion you
know what should I tell my kids about
free well like I do you lie to your kids
with you and I made a joke I said lie to
them right which given the fact that
I've written a book without lying and
and my I've taken a very public position
that basically you never lie you don't
even tell white lies and lions on the
continuum of violence and you just lie
and in in real extremity big laugh
because I was there everyone everyone
knew that I would my audience knew I was
joking but Ben didn't know I was joking
okay so Ben what left and did some
subsequent interviews saying well you
know Sam Harris's remedy for this is
that you just you know he thinks free
will is an illusion but you should lie
to your kids about it right so I said
Ben that was a joke and you know he a is
I mean if he ki he certainly suggested
in his email I haven't seen him since
but it was it seemed like he was gonna
stop doing that whereas again this what
I would absolutely expect I mean like
bet your life on expect to get from any
of these other antagonists is sorry you
said lie right like this is all right I
have the text right here yeah I'm gonna
hold you to that
right and this is this is happening
across the board on far more substantial
things like you know whether someone's a
racist whether say it's like you if it's
possible to parse your tweet or your
statement or your bad joke as you're now
a Nazi yeah right that's what people are
going to do to you until the end of time
and it's just there's there's no I mean
I've I had been living under the
illusion that it's possible to play your
game
so I'm impeccably so as to close the
door the door that ever happening like
that's like if I'm just gonna if I just
spoke clearly enough if I just responded
to enough of this crap right this would
stop happening I mean I never thought
that I'm consciously because that it
sounds ridiculous
but like that was a that was tacitly
presumed in how I was spending my time
and energy to close the door to this
stuff and now I now I basically feel
like there's almost nothing worth
responding to and yeah so when you look
back to the time that you either thought
that consciously or not does that just
seemed like naivete or it just seems
like just that the world seriously
shifted partly because of social media
where maybe maybe fifteen years ago as
someone that you know staked out some
unpopular Prussians or politically
incorrect positions that you could do it
you could clean it up in a way that
you'd be basically insulated but now
just because of the craziness of social
media it just doesn't exist yeah I think
it's largely social media I think it's
just I mean there's there's never a
common thread that will be clean for you
no matter what you do or say it's like
so if if you if your measure of
controversy worth responding to or stuff
that wasn't clear enough because
someone's still confused is what you see
in a comment thread or what you see in
your ad mentions on Twitter you'll never
be out of hell so yeah so it was a I
could have just realized this years
before I did but it was it was a kind of
you know the frog in the boiling water
what I didn't notice it was getting hot
you know and as you gradually heated it
up so yeah I was that frog and I've
since jumped out so what do you make
then of that basic premise that you've
laid out there that for some reason
whatever is happening on the left
broadly speaking is incapable of having
honest conversations I mean to you at
this point one of the things when I do
the Peterson event I tell you and I do a
little thing about the IDW and just this
crew of people and I say something about
how we have a truly diverse group
because we've got Sam Harris on the left
and and Ben Shapiro on the right and
then I throw in a couple Kanye jokes and
some other stuff but so in my mind I
guess you're still part of that and I
know the labels are all changing and
that whole thing but what do you make of
what's happening on the left and do you
still consider yourself part of that
thing that you're obviously really
struggling with at some level yeah well
yeah I'm I'm basically despite that I've
said many things about politics over the
years I'm basically a political man
politics is the most boring thing in the
universe right
and and I I've said this before I mean
one of the things that I mean strange
people actually say this is a good thing
I mean I think you've said this is a
good thing I think this is a terrible
thing the fact that we're talking about
politics so much is a sign of something
bad no no I think it's terrible I just
tweeted that the other day I think it's
terrible okay so yeah that's why I want
small government so that it can't affect
us that okay but I thought you I thought
you thought that the rise of Trump led
to this level
new level of engagement with all these
issues and that would be a good thing I
think it's I mean it's it's it's bad
that we have an uninformed electorate
and that people are disengaged
yes but the so yeah obviously you want a
hundred percent of the people in the
country to know we know how government
works I mean that would be great but
yeah the fact that politics is so
important to people the fact that their
identity is wrapped up in it the fact
that that you just can't get away from
it that's a sign of real dysfunction
that's the sign of things not working
and so you know what in my war I mean
you know I got sucked into that and I've
said as much as you know more or less
everything I have to say on certain
those issues I mean the issues aren't
changing fast enough for me to have to
keep touching it right I mean Trump
isn't that different than he was six
months ago so I don't have to keep
talking about him but I it's just yeah I
am I find it incredibly boring and
repetitive and not it doesn't repay
attention you know it's like like the
the noises you make seem ineffectual and
there's not new in new knowledge coming
your way based on those uses of
attention so it's yeah now I'm spending
less time on it both just consuming it
and putting stuff out there about it
yeah where do you think that leads us
just as a society like it does strike me
as a sickness this you know as a sort of
societal sickness that everything has
become political all the time so I I do
the first part of what you said there I
do think is good the the Trump thing
that came in and broke everything up the
idea that so many people are really a
ting what they think that's what I would
say is good the fact that everything now
has become political and sports is
absurdly political now and every TV show
and movie and everything just non-stop
endless that I think is dangerous
because it's just putting a barrier
everywhere yeah how do we how do we sort
of bring some of that back well I just
think again we have to resist the slide
into politicizing everything that's why
they I think it's the people who are not
taken in by the it's it's disconcerting
how many of the examples that come
readily to mind are on one side of the
political spectrum it's like as someone
who's on the Left yeah with respect to
almost every variable that can define
laughs so that's what I'm trying to yeah
it's so much of it is is the left but
the truth is the left is so dominant in
journalism and entertainment that I mean
and it's kind of high culture academia
as well it's like it's like if you're
gonna if you can talk about the sources
of knowledge and the sources of
information that have you know
heretofore been considered valid and
then the sources of entertainment you're
you know mean I don't know how sports
breaks but you know sports
maybe maybe sport by sport it might
change but you're talking about a
disproportionate influence from the left
and that's how that's undoubtedly a
source of the the cluelessness that the
left had about you know what was going
on in the country and the prospects of
Trump when in the election you know I
think that was there's just a naturally
an echo chamber effect but so I think
for most people that are watching us
they're probably agreeing with you right
most of my audience is going to agree
with that diagnosis do you think the
powers that be whether it's in the media
world or the political establishment or
the whatever is happening at the
universities are they getting the
message yet do you have any hope that
they're actually realizing how toxic
this thing has become well they're
getting the message that there's a
problem but my concern is that the left
seems totally capable of just taking a
pendulum swing in the other direction
into leftist identity politics I mean I
think you know it's hard to know how
fully the left has been captured by that
but it's in the reaction to try be the
you know Trump and the left are now
mirror images of one another but no and
it's I mean the answer to trump can't be
and to just take it out of you know off
Trump for a second just the answer to
the excesses of you identity politics
and populism and unreason on the right
you know can't be amplifying all of that
on the Left I just think that's it I
think it's I think it'll be just in fact
a losing strategy going forward and it's
just it's just it is more of a I mean
it's a more it's more of a renunciation
of everything that makes the left good
than it is on the right so if you go far
enough right you're not expecting to
meet kind of rational open-ended
conversation about the nature of reality
right you're expecting to meet you know
neo-nazis and the KKK and then that's
what you in fact meet right but my
problem is I'm meeting this the same
level of demagoguery and dishonesty and
cynicism and just mere gamesmanship
on the left in a much much closer to to
where you know we all are living like so
it's like just in interacting with a
reporter from you know salon or Voxx
right like like like who's who's there
I'm meeting someone who essentially has
the intellectual and moral integrity of
what the guy in the white hood you know
over on the right and that asymmetry is
is just totally alarming to me yeah so I
knew look so we'll just do a couple more
minutes on politics yeah shift to some
stuff so one of the places where
obviously we're not completely lined up
is sort of the the Trump stuff and the
reaction to all of this I think as human
beings I don't think it particularly
matters to either one of us what those
differences might be but I know our
audiences have a little bit of a
different feeling on that perhaps huh
so my general feeling again I did not
vote for Trump I voted for Gary Johnson
I would have preferred having a
president who I think really understands
three branches of government and the
history of America and all of those
simple things and that would have been
nice and the debates if anyone would
have said to him do you know what the
difference between the legislative and
executive and judicial branches are and
I think that maybe
could have caused an employer end of the
whole thing and all that but that being
said I think the wrecking ball that he
put through the machine that was dumbing
us all down that was creating this
identity politics situation and
everything else that had been so
corroded into the system I think where
we're at now I'm quite hopeful I
actually sense a lot of fertility for
ideas I think the fact that this whole
crew of people have has come together or
whether we're independent or together
whatever you want to call it the fact
that there's such interest in all of
this I think is is all good and I see
that as sort of a direct result of Trump
just shaking up the system
that being said does he lie all the time
absolutely do I think they all lie all
the time yeah did Obama lie about if you
like your hope doctor you can keep it
yeah the Syria red line Baba bhai it's
just Trump does a different series of
Lies and does them much more blatantly
why it's this area I guess I can't give
you that last thing on the scale of the
line cuz I think it's its orders of
magnitude worse I mean like not even
just one order of magnitude worse it's
like a hundredfold worse with Trump so
alright so if you take those two those
so if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor
Obamacare obviously was his biggest
public policy domestic public policy
thing yeah so that's a pretty big lie
and they pretty much admitted that he
knew he's saying it because yeah I mean
whether whether that was a liar or not
or whether he just reneged on a promise
or I'm at the Red Lion I don't really do
as a lie I just view that as a failure
of nerve it's like he drew a red line
that he probably shouldn't have drawn
because he if you thought about it he
knew he wasn't gonna go to war over it
right and then he made us look weak
because he didn't you know he the line
was crossed and we didn't respond I
think that was but it's just where we
were living in a world where you would
have a whole news cycle over Obama
wearing a tan suit right right and now
we're living in a world where a porn
star can say listen you know he's lying
about this and I have evidence and it's
like it's so it's eclipsed by the next
line he tells by the end of the bad news
cycle right so it's just I mean I mean
it's literally true to say that
Obama's presidency would have been
completely derailed by any one of maybe
a hundred things you could say Donald
Trump has said or done in the last year
I mean not even way beyond ten things I
mean I you know I can't list them now
but I mean almost anything he does on a
weekly basis if not a daily basis had
you seen Obama do it in that you know
period of the earth that you think would
have really derailed in Obama presidency
because to me it was like the media was
so far up his but they could have pretty
much gotten away with anything well I
get what you're saying that yeah they
focused on tan suits and silly nonsense
but to me I see that as almost like it's
because you guys weren't doing your job
you should have been digging a little
bit more or whatever well no but I think
it's actually true to say that Obama was
basically you know as honest as a
politician it can be and still be a
politician I'm I think I'm sure he lied
about things right yeah but there's
there's no story on Obama being just
this depraved person behind closed doors
who get who is a con artist who gets
away with everything that he can get
away with whose trailing a long list of
cat you know business and interpersonal
casualties who will tell you if you put
them on camera or you can't get them
privately these the worst person they've
ever met right that's who's president
now right it's just it's a completely
different personality and I think that I
think so whatever happens let's say good
that let's say we're living in a
universe where having a uniquely
narcissistic selfish shallow personality
in the this position of power works out
well let's just say that middle of so
let's just to take your wreckingball
theory he's kind of swung through here
he's disrupted everything you know I do
view him as I've said before is a kind
of evil Chauncey Gardiner character I
don't view him as this sort of mastery I
think Scott Adams is completely out to
lunch on I don't think he's this genius
manipulator I mean he's got he's got
some talents obviously right but I think
you think it's much less calculating
much less character
thank him contradicting himself two
sentences later right when he says you
know this is an amazing letter you'd all
like to read this letter and that he
says two sentences later I haven't read
the letter yeah that's not calculated
he's just not doesn't have the cog he
can't take the cognitive overhead to
even figure out what you know what was
logically implied by the last thing he
said right so he's not the truth is he's
not he lies all the time
but worse than lying and this is the
great distinction that the philosopher
Harry Frankfurt made in his book on
[ __ ] worse than lying is that he's
[ __ ] in all the time and the
difference between line and bullshitting
is that if I'm gonna lie to you I'm
paying attention to what I know react
well I know it what is true I know you
know what is true and I'm trying to
insert a lie into the space provided in
a way that you won't notice right like
I'm having to keep track of reality in
order to lie to you successfully I
understand your logical expectations I
understand that if I tell you that you
know I was an hour late here because the
traffic was so bad I can't say in the
next sentence oh I left an hour late
from my house right so like so so the
bullshitter isn't doing any of that the
bullshitter is just talking right and
therefore has renounced the reality
testing he has to do to lie successfully
and he's just he has the burden is not
on him to make any sense at all in the
end and that for to an amazing degree
not entirely I think he does actually
lie strategically sometimes but to an
amazing degree and this is why I think
it's so harmful about his presidency
whatever happens with North Korea or
anything else that we might you know
care about to an amazing degree he has
revealed that half of our society will
accept somebody who is just bullshitting
all the time about things great and
small I mean doesn't matter how
important or how inconsequential porn
stars you know what you know what just
happened with the g7 you know what was
said behind closed doors what he's going
to say to to a some maniac with with
nukes
there's just say a wee
completely forsaken any expectation of a
reality-based conversation and many
people seem to revel in it many people
seem to think this is just this is just
good fun it's like this is the you know
the ends it's a bit of the wrecking ball
theory yeah gone to some nihilistic
extreme where it's just let's just you
know let's just burn it all out you know
like like there's just nothing you know
there's nothing there was nothing worth
maintaining about our institutions about
our norms about our traditions about you
know the expectations of our of our
other countries that are our allies you
know like who cares if if all of our
traditional allies don't know what to
think about the president because he
said one thing five minutes ago when he
says the opposite thing now and they're
all left with their jaws on the floor
right that's just comedy for what 40% of
America I think there's a real
consequence of that because I because
what what Trump has revealed is that
there's a space for a truly terrible
calculating person you know like the the
the sinister person with a real ideology
not just so you think someone
potentially worse than him oh yeah oh
yeah I mean we've just we've proven to
ourselves that literally anyone who who
can connect certain dots I mean who
anyone who can connect the dots of you
know I'm not even sure what these dots
are but I mean obviously Trump connected
some of them you know Fame and and a
certain kind of charisma you know it did
the kind of populist an ability to to
strike the populist note in a way that's
compelling someone who's could be way
worse and way smarter and and have a
very different agenda can become
president and I think that's you know I
mean it's good perhaps is good to know
that but it's just I think we now know
that about ourselves yeah is this then
weird so I think you know that I'm
certainly not a nihilist and I'm
definitely not somebody that wanted to
burn the whole thing down but I but I do
view this reckoning as basically good as
long as this purpose other person does
in magic
appear out of it and I also sense that
that the time of craziness that we're in
right now and this endless inability to
have these honest conversations and I
and I agree with you on his basic
management of truth or whatever you
whatever you want management of Tehran's
are interesting phrase yeah whatever
that is that I sense there is going to
be a rebound towards sanity that at some
point you can't always have the wrecking
ball always have the guy that's flipping
everything over and destroying it and
that if our institutions are strong
enough and if there's enough sane people
out there and enough people that are
listening to thoughtful conversations
and I think we both agree there's a lot
of people growing in that regard that
the next version of whatever happens at
an election is going to come from
something much saner yeah from before we
where we were before because that's
where they were just getting a lot of
[ __ ] from the media and from
everything else that we might actually
get a rebound into sanity no cuz I what
I see is the the Republican Party has
been destroyed where the Republican
Party has become Trump's party it's just
this populist pandering I mean they're
just all trying to figure out what to do
in his wake but nobody I mean it's there
there's no coherent platform anymore
there and as we've said the left has
swung into this insane just just
victimology echo chamber of identity
politics where everyone's a racist yeah
right so I guess maybe that's sort of
the root of where our little disconnect
is on this because I fear that much more
I think that that thing that's happening
on the Left this identity politics thing
I think that's the thing that could
actually truly upend the entire American
experiment the idea that we would end up
looking at each other only on these
immutable characteristics and hiring
each other only on these things and
having quotas and ripping apart the the
good pieces of multiculturalism that
we've done here better than anybody and
the melting pot that we've done better
that it will cause us to all be horrific
ly suspicious of each other and and
angry at each other really for no reason
other than the way we
look and I'm not discounting anything
you're saying about what's happening on
the right although I do see a streak of
libertarianism on the right that I
really like I think there actually has
been a rebirth you know a guy like
Shapiro is obviously not a real Trump
guy at heart and he's arguing a lot of
libertarian stuff that I like I mean
maybe you don't like it as much I think
it's a decent place to be arguing from
but I guess maybe that is where our our
little disconnect is on that that the
thing on the Left I view as much scarier
I think it's a much more of an immediate
threat and I say that knowing full well
that Trump has the nuclear codes so
maybe that's maybe that's a little yeah
I think they're both enormous problems I
don't know which every you know the
Trump thing could seem fine until
something horrific happens right so it's
like and you know it's just it is in
fact hard to know what's happening and
what risks were running so it's like you
know the economy seems to be doing good
by what metric but the stock market
hasn't imploded right though so but only
if it's low consumer confidence is high
black and Latino unemployment really low
I mean right but I mean so there are
ways to parse all of those numbers that
that are less optimistic so you know
like the employment numbers are low
because lots of people just fallen out
of the the job search but and the you
know the stock market represent of
Americans or in the stock market you
know it's like 92 percent of Americans
are not even exposed to the stock market
right or at least directly so those
numbers could be a little off but it's
something like that the but all of that
would change radically the moment
something you know so that the the
left's worst fears about Trump or
realize them at the moment he does
something that just gets you know gets
us far closer to obvious you know war or
actually into one and it's clearly the
wrong war you know the fact that I mean
I think I think that the the the u.s. no
longer stand at least in the eyes of the
world the u.s. no longer stands for
sanity on some fundamental questions of
human values and like you know you know
whether it's you know climate change and
environmentalism and doing something
saying with respect to that or
you know human rights I mean he just he
just took a meeting with with the
perhaps the greatest human rights
violator the certainly the current
generation and human you know it's just
clear now that the US will will
glad-hand a dictator and say nothing
about the fact that he's running a gulag
system and they have been for four
decades that used to be unthinkable and
that's and said that that that
extinguishes a certain hope of kind of
moral high-ground that the rest of the
world I think rightly depended on us for
and given the current occupant of the
Oval Office
you know we've completely abandoned that
right so I think but it's hard to it's
hard to price in those changes I don't
know what the consequences of all of
that is right so I guess the part that
still seems odd to me is like you know
when Obama ran he said you know we have
to sit down with these people he said he
wanted to sit down with akhmad energy I
know with no you know prior discussions
or whatever that's basically what Trump
did here now I'm not saying Trump's the
right guy to do it maybe is in some
insane way and maybe is it but most of
those cases there would have been some
lambasting of the person about human
rights you know it's like I mean that
the standard if it was Hillary Clinton
doing any of these things yeah at least
you know there would be that the norm of
acknowledging that that I mean so some
of you just compare what Trump said
about Kim jong-un
yeah the statements were okay good to
what's actually going on I mean so we
have someone who is presiding over the
starvation and just I mean it's beyond
Orwellian immiseration of his people and
it's like if you are caught saying the
wrong thing or passing the wrong book to
your neighbor or you've tuned your radio
to receive a broadcast from South Korea
you're sent to the gulag and your
progeny are sent to the gulag and
they're down to the third generation
right I mean that's that's the
punishment for this and we have the
president knighted States saying that
he's a great guy he's a
intelligent guy he loves his people and
that's a verbatim quote he loves his
people I'm not surprised by that it's
just it's like well I don't even know
what it means is there anyone in this
country who it's just like there's so
many layers at which we have lost sight
of reality here that's like it so I
don't know where the freefall stops like
on one level there's a sense that he's
he's lying right like he's saying
something he knew us know is untrue
right so like he knows what's going on
he knows what life is like okay in in
North Korea Korea so he knows that to
say that this man loves his people is a
misrepresentation but what do people
actually think I think I think it's I
think it's there's another layer beyond
that no he actually doesn't know that
like he's so ignorant of what's
happening in the world that he's just
talking and there's there's no burden on
him to represent reality at all or
there's a layer beyond that it simply
doesn't matter like like the difference
between those two things lying and
bullshitting doesn't matter and we're
not even going to spend the the
nanosecond it takes to judge between
them and beyond that we're we're not
even going to notice that he said
anything strange there and that's it
that's kind of where most of the country
is it's like we now have someone in
office who will say things that make
absolutely no sense and they they are
meant to map on the most consequential
examples of human suffering in our time
right and the most consequential risks
we run as a civilization we're talking
about nuclear war here and the
conversations that can be had to prevent
it and he's saying things that are not
only just untrue and obscenely untrue no
one's even noticing and no one's even
noticing that no one is noticing I mean
like so this is like I don't know where
we are now well it's just like I don't
think there's a name for this right and
how about I think that matters do you
think we have until if what you're
saying is right
how many firewalls left are there before
we're really
like like some true dystopian complete
inability to communicate but let me just
clarify here I'm not even judging
whether anything bad happened in
Singapore like I so it's totally
possible that the evil Chauncey Gardiner
character could be the thing that
successfully gets us to have a better
relationship with with North Korea so I
think that's what's that that's possible
I'm not saying I'm not saying I know
that's impossible
yeah it doesn't seem like a great bet to
me and does it's not the way I would
it's not and even if it's possible I
don't think it's the best possible
strategy it would be better to have
someone who actually read the briefing
books knows the history of negotiations
knows the possibility that he's being
duped it's paying attention to all of
that even while let's say playing like
the madman if in fact that's the right
strategy in this game of chicken butt so
there's nothing optimal about this but
I'm just saying I'm not climb not saying
that that my worrying about the what's
happening it's not predicated on the
claim that oh this whole thing with
North Korea is gonna be a disaster right
if it's successful that still doesn't
answer my primary concern about what
we've done to ourselves in terms of our
politics yeah so how do we negotiate
those two things let's just say for a
second that despite all the lies and
with he lies about absolutely everything
okay despite all of this craziness and
nonsense and all of that that basically
for years past let's say the economy is
basically fine we don't get into some
extra intractable war let's say
something good comes out of the North
Korea situation basically things have
been okay you know there is a massive
terror attack or something I would say
we've dodged many many bullets and and
that we got very lucky yeah I would
what's impossible to argue is that this
is all a brilliant plan that has been
thought through from the beginning on
the part of Trump I think that something
is just no evidence for that at all
right it's not that he is he is deeply
informed about world history and current
events and all of the all of the
information one would think you would
need to know to game this out inside
some gene
level you know four dimensional chess
right right to follow the Scott Adams
program and so that's not happening so
but we could live in a world where
having someone who kind of fundamentally
is just a reality TV show star thrust
into this position of immense
responsibility we could live in a world
where that can work out in surprising
ways or at least not cause some kind of
disaster yeah I hope we live in that
world I mean I'm you know I hope that he
succeeds in every way we would want a
president to succeed and then I also
hope he doesn't get reelected you know
it's like III think it's still it's it's
obvious to me that we're paying an
immense price even if terrible things
don't happen
so if terrible things don't happen and
the left sort of continues with the
track that I think we both see if I'm
right could you possibly vote for one of
those people like would you feel that
this is this could override everyone
well it depends who the person is and
what the what the trade-offs are I think
you know I you know in my world almost
anyone would be better than Trump but
you know give me the the sufficiently
obnoxious choice on the left and that
you know I would I could rethink that
yeah I think it's well I think I think
you mean we think that not to vote for
Trump but you'd end up voting for third
parties yeah I'm a or that it wouldn't
matter you know we could be in a
situation where it's just both sides are
so terrible that you know let's just
toss a coin yeah but it's just it should
be omits I don't know how we got here
we've got more than 300 million people
in this country there are many really
impressive people in this country how is
it that we can't feel the candidate who
has obvious depth of knowledge and
obvious moral compass and you know sound
goals do you think it's just that nobody
that was truly good that was truly
knowledgeable that was truly decent and
all the things that we'd really want
from the president we never do it now in
a time when every one of your texts will
be gone through every your internet
search history your every little
relationship you've ever had that the
ability to do
deeper and dive into more of just the
nonsense that no good person who's ever
lived a full life and made mistakes and
done drugs or whatever else it is would
ever want to do it so instead you get
sort of this shameless person who has
done probably everything and all sorts
of crazy things but just doesn't care
what you know whereas a good decent
person who wants to live a decent life
and have a family and all and I'm not
even commenting on it seemed like he's
family really loves it so I don't mean
that but that that just someone the
person that you're looking for in that
imaginary equation would never want to
do it that's not someone who would opt
in well I think they're people who are
who will opt in who are normal I just
whether or not they will get noticed and
get promoted to the other side for
instance I just interviewed a guy who
you may not have heard of Andrew yang
who's already declared his candidacy for
2020 as a Democrat he's a Silicon Valley
guy I just recorded a podcast with him
and they could be the next one I release
a very interesting guy whose whole
platform it seems is universal basic
income I mean he's just he's looking at
what's happening in tech and automation
and AI and he says you know this as many
of us have said or at least worried that
that there will be jobs lost in in the
near term that aren't coming back and
aren't converting to new just not it's
not like yeah you know any analogy you
want to draw out of previous moments in
economic history you know there will be
truck drivers losing jobs and we're not
going to retrain those truck drivers as
software engineers and this is going to
be forget about all the other
highfalutin concerns about AI this is
going to be catastrophic if we don't
figure out how to deal with it and he
thinks ubi is the solution and he his
book is a he wrote a book that that in
very stark terms puts it all in
perspective his book as the the war on
normal people but I've just I'll have a
podcast well that's not what your next
book yeah but he's you know he's a very
articulate guy he's he's you know
thought about these issues deeply
whether he's right about ubi being the
panacea you know I think this is
certainly open for debate but
he strikes me as I mean I don't know him
I did one podcast with him but he
strikes me as a you know completely sane
normal non fame-seeking person who just
wants to screw up his life by becoming
president and and because he's worried
is just simply worried about the future
his kids are going to inherit yeah all
right so one more on the political stuff
a little shift to some other stuff so
did you catch I know you've been on the
show a couple times do you have to catch
real time on Friday or see the clip of
Bill basically saying that he's sort of
hoping for a recession because that'll
wake people up did you know no I miss
I'm at least a week behind but no I
didn't yeah so bill in effect said that
if it takes a recession to derail this
thing that that that he'd before that
right and you know I like Bill a lot you
know I I I've loved to have him on the
show to discuss some of this stuff but I
thought that moment of him saying that a
guy whose product no idea what he's
worth he's probably worth at least fifty
million bucks or something crazy which I
don't begrudge him any of that of course
but what he said they're so caught me as
just this is what people hate about
liberals liberals whatever you know or
lefties or whatever it is like this idea
that yeah you may not like Trump and you
may joke about them all time and all
this stuff and you may think he's lying
all the time but that what you would
want is a recession which you'll survive
because you've got millions and millions
of dollars but it did maybe my first
thought when I saw it was that right
after the election for as much as you
despise this man and are so fearful of
all of the things that he will wrought
upon us you you made the analogy about
the the pilot in the plane yeah and I
know that's the right analogy and I
thought that's what we need right now
and and I discuss this a little bit with
Rogan today and and that's where his
take was also yeah well so I so I
haven't seen the clip from Bill and so I
can imagine it leads to charitable
interpretations of it that take that
that callousness off it one would just
be the idea that were running such an
intolerable risk with this guy at the
helm and the only way he's going to be
voted out is to have something like a
recession so there definitely was
an element of pressure so like I'm it's
like so it's this is we're running every
day you wake up and don't think about it
you're running the risk of nuclear
catastrophe with this guy that's you
know 50% more than it should be or that
would otherwise be and that the the
price of that again a price you're not
aware of pain because we're just talking
about hypotheticals right it's just risk
increased risk it's worth doing this
some other you know catastrophic change
if it's the thing that's gonna get us a
new president and and so I mean that
that would be defensible if you actually
thought that that was in fact the
situation we're in but you know I don't
know what he was actually thinking yeah
isn't it nice that you give the
charitable interpretation I don't want
to just see what you're it's really not
surprising in this case because he's a
friend but it's I would you know I try
to do that even when I'm thinking about
I mean truth is I do that with Trump
like the thing that I find so
intolerable yeah about the left is also
exemplified in how they attack Trump for
things that he's not guilty of clearly I
mean there's no one who despises this
man more than me I mean yeah I don't
know how you compare these things but
like I'll go to the mat with anyone yeah
I gotta you bro I mean I can I can I can
talk endlessly about what's wrong with
this guy
yeah but when people want people on the
left or didn't know that mean I'm not I
don't mean just fringe left I mean the
New York Times yeah go after him for
things that seem clearly just calculated
to mislead I mean they're just
disingenuous it's it's just a bit I I
get is annoyed by that as by anything so
I mean I'm probably within my own mind I
feel pretty balanced in how careful I am
you know so like for a man to take the
like the ms-13 thing I mean have you
seen what's going on with ms-13 on Long
Island did you did you watch that
frontline I didn't see the frontline
okay so it's the fact that anyone is
minimizing the significance of how
horrible this is yeah right it's just
and playing politics with that and
catching him saying like you know these
people are animals
and then using that to mean that he
thinks everyone coming from Latin
America as an animal it's I mean that's
it's just so toxic it's what I view that
as different somehow than all right
forget the buzz feeds and salons and
that whole set that we already talked
about but this I think now with the New
York Times and CNN where they're doing
this now yeah that to me is something
that is truly systemic Lee that's
different and that's extremely dangerous
like what could possibly be happening
there at a at a sort of systemic level
that makes sense that they can get away
with this stuff well no they know five
minutes later it's going to be exposed
well I don't know if they know that but
but I think the fact that you see it
that way is a measure of how important a
reality-based conversation is and how
different the expectation is of
something like the New York Times versus
something like Breitbart right right so
like it matters that the New York Times
gets it wrong it matters at the New York
Times is it all clickbait t but a right
and so and then when you compare that to
something like Breitbart you know it's
just there's a fundamentally different
expectation and so well that's why
people people give me [ __ ] all the time
oh I'm always attacking New York Times
and CNN it's like those are the ones I
think matter yeah everyone else is
attacking or that I don't expect to do
real journalism they're just not comes
yeah that's all they are yeah but I mean
it matter it matters across the board
because people are confused by this
people think that Vox is like the New
York Times right and and it's confusing
because you can find articles on box
that are fantastic I mean it's just
there's a there's a real range of
quality you get everywhere now and and
you there shouldn't be a wide range in
something like the New York Times right
and and it's and we're seeing this you
know like as any of us get close to
being part of the news story right
whether it's a directly on you or its
told about one of your friends it's like
New York Times I mean someone I know the
New York Times Bret Stevens
who moved from The Wall Street Journal
and now he's in the opinion right of the
New York Times he just went after Ilan
for I mean it was just a pure clickbait
hit piece that was - it was just you
know Breitbart level trash right I mean
it was it was wrong in every respect
apart from the fact that it be that it
summarized you know some of the economic
skepticism about Tesla but I mean he's
me buddy that either wasn't really the
issue no it may be because he basically
said that Elon is silicon valley's Trump
Yeah right and a con man and it's just
just know he's got this know they're
there he's lying about everything
I mean if ever there were a person you
can't say his is without substance and
there's a just a pure con man it's Elon
I mean it's like it's like he could fail
to do half the things he's promising to
do and he does more than the next
productive most productive hundred
people it's just it's insane so and I
will you know I was I was it was
hilarious because I this all was timed
with my getting off Twitter as I said by
like nine to five percent but I was on
long enough to notice this and and and
just take a shot at at Brett in a you
know in response because it was
intolerable to me but the New York Times
somewhat respectfully right yeah and
then okay you didn't do it the way that
most people do which was just like a
blurted out no no what I let him know
because I was like I'm a fan of breads
may I publicly celebrated also on
Twitter his move to the New York Times
like I congratulated him and you know I
think he's if he's a very smart guy you
know for whatever you know you dogmatic
reason he was sort of destined to get
this this wrong but he's so totally
wrong that it's just it is a real
consequence the New York Times can't
afford to be this wrong about in this
case you know the prospects of a company
like Tesla and in a clean tech and you
know it's just it was all of this
connects obviously with climate change
and you know huge important issues yeah
and I think that one I don't know Brett
personally but it seems like what what
this was all about was because Elan was
attacking the media
because he was unhappy right now it's
the way some stuff was reported yeah and
then Brett was obviously being defensive
over the media yeah but I was very
pleased watching Ilan's thread on this
because I was like yeah we need more
people to be attacking this you know
otherwise the the times won't turn
around yeah yeah well you know I don't
know whether he's doing himself harm by
engaging in that way I mean he this
could be just something that happens to
somebody once they crossed you know the
20 million mark on Twitter it's like you
become like Trump in that respect then
you just decide to you know use the
Twitter that way but it's I mean on one
level it's refreshing that you have
someone you have a CEO who's got this
transparent with what he's thinking and
this and just engaging on all of his
issues with with you know people in his
ad mentions but it's I don't know I
thought you know I think it's again I
think social media the net result for
virtually everyone is you're lucky to
get back to zero you know like that's
the the if you if you're going to take
an inventory of what was gained in the
end by all of this all of the energy
you've spent fighting with people or
correcting the record it's your let
you're lucky to have got any right you
can check all the times you've owned
someone versus right you know all the
times they owned you and all right so
let's put all of that aside I do want to
do a sort of deep dive on the on the
Jordan stuff because I think maybe we
can set the table and in a nice way for
your conversation but what's on your
mind more than anything else right now
but that's not political or not
unrelated to the conversation with
George yes like what what are you really
thinking about right now
well I'm thinking more about core or
things that interest me like the nature
of consciousness you know and and just
how to live a good life given the fact
that we wake up every day not knowing
how long we've got and we're absolutely
sure that we don't get this day again so
it's like how do how to meaningfully
engage moment a moment in our lives in a
way that's rewarding and and
minimizes unnecessary suffering and
increases joy and and insight and
creativity and and so it's it for me as
you know meditation is part of that
certainly and I've just have just come
out with this meditation app that is now
in beta and in on Apple and the Android
beta dopey it's probably at a month away
this has been taken it's completely
mystifying to me that it's taken me this
long to build an app and I've talked
about something over there you didn't
understand but immediately it literally
is just a glorified mp3 player and yet
it's taken a lot longer than two years
and just vast expense to build this
thing but in any case I'm I'm happy with
the the iteration that's coming out now
and so that's I'm gonna it's not just a
meditation app it'll have my podcast and
other content I put on it but I'm
thinking my my withdrawal from the
toxicity of social media and and the
political conversations has led me to
just clear a lot more space frankly for
for things that I think are are
interesting and and profound in a
durable way that way you're not going to
look back five years from now or 20
years from now and wonder why you spent
your time on those things like and so
much of all of our lives but you know
like my life and my public life in
particular has been spent on things
where I look back it just looks like one
opportunity costs after another I mean
virtually everything that I I'm well
known for talking about has been a waste
of time and and that's it's it's been
some sense is necessary it's not that
I've squandered my time in a way that I
didn't think was necessary but okay but
it woke up a lot of people along the way
yeah so hence I felt it was necessary
but it was an opportunity cost it's like
it's it's easy in some level on some of
its trying to get to zero it's like can
we get to the starting point where
we then can advance the conversation
pass what we should have every reason to
already understand to be true so I think
a lot of people are lining up behind
that and again it still gets to where I
think this thing is full right now I do
think there has been some sort of shift
I can see it when I'm with the Petersons
audiences I can see it just there's a
new conversation happening that people
are starting to arm themselves with like
how do we move forward through this
craziness whether we all agree on belief
or lack of belief or a religion or some
of that other some of that other stuff
yeah you know one of the things that you
told me the first time we met which now
it was the first time you did my shows
September 9th 2015 it seems like 87
lifetimes ago that was the first show
first show yeah that was a tour or TV
wave everyone which the whole purpose of
having you on the show was to clean up
so much of the mess right and I think we
did a pretty decent job but at the same
time because of all this you know the
people that want to drag you just keep
dragging you but one of the most
interesting things and I know you don't
believe in karma in in any kind of
traditional sense but that you were on
real-time to talk about waking up
talking to yak about the book tour that
was about a guide to spirituality
without religion right thus your book
tour got ransacked by that so it's like
in karma but it's kind of it's just like
whoa that's something pretty profound
I've actually never thought about what
my life would have been like without
social media at that point like I like
because the consequence in my life of
that you know fight with Ben Affleck on
real time was basically a year spent
digging out from that charge yes like
okay so your your views about Islam or
racist anyone ever called you racist
before that or bigoted or anyone of any
consequence like was there anything well
I mean I'm sure I'm sure but I don't I
don't remember it being something I had
to respond to yeah I think and yeah but
it was just that was so captivating to
people and there's so much so much spun
out after that but again had I not been
on social media it might have in my
world it might have blown over and in
two week
right sorry I might have not felt there
was anything to respond to and I could
have just moved on directly to talking
about meditation and you know a rational
take on spirituality and I don't know
but it's certainly possible that that's
the case so all right so meditation what
do you think is the right amount then of
spirituality for the amount of people
that are watching this but maybe we're
on the fence about religion or or
actually our atheist but that are trying
to figure out some spiritual sense of
going forward and cleaning out some of a
clutter that were inundated with what do
you think is sort of the easiest way to
enter that that world well I'm sure this
is something Jordan and I are gonna get
we're gonna butt heads over but it the
level at which people have been primed
to think about meaning and profundity
and awe and the sacred and spirituality
by traditional religion especially you
know Abrahamic religion is certainly not
necessary and it you know I would argue
it's it's not at all useful when you
talk about what the the opportunity
actually is what's what's available to
you as a as a conscious agent in this
moment and it's not an accident that
people are going to the east and to east
see the Eastern tradition for insight
with respect to this particular variable
of just just how to pay attention to
experience closely enough so as to
notice something worth noticing in the
West people have been you know praying
to Yahweh for 2,000 years to do that
right and it's it's it's explicitly
dualistic it's explicitly hostage to
this notion of Revelation the notion of
a God with whom you're in relationship
who can who can be propitiated with
prayer or not it's just it's hooked to
all of the mythologizing that the Jordan
is so enamored of and in my world it's
totally unnecessary and totally all
that's confusing it's like it's
needlessly confusing right
and it would be just as confusing to go
to Tibetan Buddhism and acquire all the
religiosity of the Tibetans or to go to
you know the Indian tradition and take
on all of the the the ordinary forms of
Hinduism you know the exoteric you know
non that the dualistic forms of Hinduism
so you're like you know just how much
time should we spend thinking about the
monkey god Hanuman or you know Ganesh
the elephant headed Ganesh and did Shiva
really you know tear his head off and
put an elephant head on there like do we
its like these book you could run the
same game that Jordan is doing with
Judeo the judeo-christian tradition with
Hinduism and think that somehow all of
that all of that myth making and
storytelling is necessary I'm not saying
there's no I'm not saying you can't find
people who have some good result in
their lives by thinking of you know
thinking they're in relationship to
Hanuman every day right
but there's there's something truly
Universal and not at all bound by
culture and not at all bound by history
about the nature of consciousness and
that can be realized directly and that a
meditation is simply a tool for doing
that and it just it is just an accident
and an explainable accident but it's an
accident of history that there are
certain traditions that got the point
very early in an in a way that's
uncontaminated by needless concepts and
certain traditions don't have it at all
and and Buddhism is is unique in that
you can find a strand in it that really
is not it's not even a religion it is
just simply a methodology for paying
attention to the nature of consciousness
and you can and you need not take on any
Buddhism you know even as a philosophy
in order to do that and so you know you
know you know my book waking up and in
whenever I talk about this yeah I try to
boil it down you see here somewhere if
you want to reference it yeah no no no I
still remember what I think on that
regard but yeah you can you can get to
the heart of the matter without
presupposing any religious nonsense and
the heart of the matter is that you know
consciousness again as I said is the one
thing in this universe that can't be an
illusion I mean whatever we are whatever
however consciousness is integrated with
physical reality we that's still a
question mark whether we're being run on
the you know the supercomputer and in
some you know future state of humanity
and we're just a simulation or whether
you know we're that we're you know have
been invented by aliens but what this
universe could be strange in ways that
we can't even imagine
still there's there's this there's this
moment where something seems to be
happening there's something that is like
to be you whatever you are right
whatever the physics are this second yes
that is the that is the fact of
consciousness that is what we mean by
consciousness I mean this it's possible
to define consciousness in other ways
those those those definitions are
confusing do you think Jordan disagrees
with that because I don't know I when we
haven't talked about it but no I would
doubt yeah I don't think you can
coherently disagree with that it's like
this is this is you know this could be a
dream right you could be asleep and
dreaming and we're not even doing this
podcast but still the fact that it seems
like something at this moment to be you
that is what that is what we mean by
consciousness and the it is just a fact
that you can pay attention to that
circumstance carefully enough to
discover certain things that are
profound and surprising and do actually
link up with the phenomenology of
religion I mean so it's a little at
least some of what Jesus said about what
it's like to be Jesus is is discoverable
as a property of your own consciousness
now and you don't have to be a Christian
to do that and so it is with Buddha or
any other you know any other matriarch
or patriarch of the world's religious
traditions and you don't need these
these additional cultural artifacts that
clearly are the product of the fact that
you that people were isolated from one
another and speaking different languages
and never corresponding about you know
we there claims there's just there is a
deeper universal culture free reality
which we all
subjectively and that that is
consciousness and its contents in each
moment and one thing you can realize
about consciousness is that the self you
take yourself to be in each moment that
the feeling that you are riding around
in your head as the unchanging center of
your life that's an illusion and you can
discover that to be an illusion you can
you can lose that feeling of being a an
occupant of your body like not being
identical to your body but being sort of
just behind your face as a subject who's
appropriating experience in each moment
who's in you know in addition to
thoughts arising it's felt that there's
a thinker of the thoughts right that's
an illusion that can be cut through and
when you do cut through it your
experience changes in ways that that
again link up with some of the ideals of
you know traditional contemplative and
spiritual and mystical claims but again
you can do the we can have a 21st
century science based conversation about
that and that's I said that's what I
think is worth paying attention to all
right so before we dive into some of the
specifics with Jordan do you hit do you
ever get [ __ ] from the Atheist community
for even going this far into
spirituality oh yeah is that really like
is that a common thing because that that
world of it I think I've clearly missed
it so yeah yeah yeah no I mean I often
joke about the fact that the the talk I
gave at the the atheist Alliance
conference in INGOs 2007 was the only
talk I'm aware of that ever started with
a standing ovation and ended with booze
and people leave it and it was this I
made two points there that that people
found in digestible one as I said you
know we don't need this word atheists or
atheism and and we don't need to be we
don't need to be a victim group that
meets in bad hotels and talks about you
know our identity right yeah and and so
and it was just it was just a fact that
I never it was just an accident but it
interests true that the book that got me
inducted into the
you know the the pantheon of atheists in
this generation the end of faith was a
book where I never used the word atheist
and never I never suppressed the word
atheist it just never occurred to me to
use it I wasn't thinking in terms of
atheists I was thinking in terms of
science and common sense and evidence
and you know the other obvious the for
the flay of flagrant violations of all
that on the religious side of the
conversation so I was um I don't think
we we need the word I mean that you know
we can this is a debatable point
politically maybe maybe the kid maybe
I'm wrong about this and it's useful it
or at least useful for a time but I
think what was the second thing that you
said in that and then so it says then I
followed that with a conversation you
know about 20 minutes of my talking
about spirituality and and the
contemplatively Rian's of the sort I
just mentioned here and I said that it
was a problem in the Atheist community
that basically this variable of atheism
and and a repudiation of religion was
selecting for people who for the most
part either hadn't had certain kinds of
experiences or or viewed them as just
purely pathological like these were
people who you know hadn't done
psychedelics or came away thinking well
that was just madness or that was you
know those are just drug experiences and
just that they had some deflationary
account of all that that that basically
said there's no there there you know
there's nothing sacred we're just you
know we're just bags of chemicals and
we're going to die and then nothing and
then nothing happens thereafter and it
matters that you have people who don't
have real powers of introspection so as
to notice notice that there's something
profound to be gleaned by paying
attention to your experience and and I
used to be one of those people I mean I
you know I've said that but for
psychedelics I think you know if you had
if you had taught me to meditate when I
was 18 I think I was a again I didn't
think of myself as an atheist I didn't
think in those categories but I was a I
was astride and atheist and when I would
meet someone I remember
meeting someone and remember when they
taught I was in the in the the great
books seminar in as a freshman in
college and the Bible was one of the
great books and I remember just you know
vilifying the Bible you know to my
professor because because it's just like
what is this theocratic insanity we're
having to read here like that like she
thought yeah this is this is not nearly
as good as the other stuff you're having
us read and the meeting half the class
that believes this stuff is not just a
book right it's like I was so it's funny
to look back on that because I was like
you know I was as militant an atheist as
I ever was as a professional atheist
right and I didn't even have the
category of atheism in my head right but
then I you know took MDMA for the first
time and and took acid after that and
discovered a range of experience that I
was just fundamentally blind - just just
cognitively emotionally and every other
you know channel you know like this was
a total revelation to me that it was
possible to to have consciousness appear
that way right and how do you know when
you're when you're doing MDMA or people
are taking you haven't done ayahuasca
right no right or when people do all
these things how do you know where it
where it's just something that you need
inside you versus true or I guess that
you would count that as as true
consciousness or truth so whatever is
true as a matter of reality out there
one thing that can't be doubted is that
that you take one of these drugs and it
proves to you that it's possible to have
a different kind of experience or now
you could be psychosis right but like
it's still instructive to realize that
you you are having a you're tending to
get up every morning and be very
recognizable to yourself I mean you are
very much like you were yesterday and
you're and you're beat you're being
buffeted within the bounds of you know
it was positive and negative experience
that is very familiar to you
and at you know if you were at all like
me at that at that point my life there
was absolutely nothing within that
channel that was fundamentally
surprising in a way that would would
answer to the name of you know
spirituality or or you know anything
profound for like it there's nothing if
if I if you had taken me into the
religious section of a book the
bookstore that or the mystical section
of a bookstore I would read all of that
and it would be evocative of nothing for
me it's like it's just like that there's
just these people you're either
conscious frauds or they're suffering
from some kind of psychopathology right
and that is what many atheists believe
about somebody like Jesus or the food
like this is probably an epileptic right
and we know that temporal lobe epilepsy
can give you you know you know or you
know migraine auras can make you think
you're having visions right so this is
the kind of thing you get from you know
the James randy's of the world right and
I mean it's no deep knock on James Randi
I think he's done very important things
for for you know the skeptical community
and to you know debunk religious
[ __ ] which again I think is
dangerous and divisive and confusing and
leads people to waste a lot of time my
mister sorry but but you don't think
that that line of thinking though the
James Randi line I think it just leaves
you with enough of a of a human
experience is that a fair way to
summarize of a full experience yeah well
it's just that there is there is
something absolutely profound and even
self transcendence about what we are
subjectively I mean it's just that
consciousness is consciousness is the
only thing that matters on some level
and it's the only space in which
anything can matter it's the space in
which values can be discovered it's the
it's the the space in which we discover
just how good the or bad the universe
can be right and this this is the
opportunity everything else is just a
thought everything else is your memory
of yesterday or your expectation of some
future moment where you are going to be
conscious
right so you're always you're always
ever here in this space where the lights
are on and if you when the lights go off
if you you know you lose consciousness
in anesthesia or death or your deep
sleep although I think that the jury's
still out on whether deep sleep is a
state of unconsciousness you know then
then there's just the absence of all of
that but here as a matter of your own
your own subjectivity there is just this
space and this is the space in which
every mystic every founder of a
religion-- every you know every person
has ever had his mind blown on
psychedelics or an eye on ayahuasca or
every shaman every this is the space in
which epiphanies are had and claims true
or false about the nature of reality are
made and the thing that has been
overlooked to it to an astonishing
degree in the Western tradition in
particular is that is that introspection
can be a methodology that is that it can
be engaged with real intellectual
honesty and a spirit of you know
empirical you know first-person
empirical experiment it can now be
correlated with you know third-person
methods of you know studying people's
brains while they you know have these
kinds of insights but introspection was
just stillborn in the West 150 years ago
when you know people like William James
we're trying to get it off the ground
and what you have in place of a really
intelligent conversation about the
nature of human consciousness you have
people's lingering attachment to
judeo-christian religion in the West
right apart from what has been imported
for with you know from something like
Buddhism into science now I mean you
have you know there's a dozens of
neuroscience labs now that study
meditation and their you know a lot of
these scientists are essentially
closeted Buddhists but and this is this
will this will be I'm sure something
Jordan and I disagree about or at least
this will this will be a part of the
conversation we need to have
so much of what he thinks is is profound
and non-negotiable and just-just-just in
our bones based on our appearance in the
West there's necessary this
judeo-christian mishegoss he's got going
on it's it's just not I mean it's just
it actually isn't it's not doing that
it's not doing the necessary work he he
claims it is and even if it's were and
again I'm not denying that you can't
have certain experiences that are seem
meaningful given that frame I mean this
do you know before Jordan was doing this
you know he had Joseph Campbell and the
whole you know men's movement you know
he had Robert Bly and you know other
other people who were who were
absolutely entranced by the power of
story and you know all of the the
history you know cross-culturally of you
know powerful stories being told and
just how lives can be framed by story
yes that is part of you know the
possible range of human experience but
there's something deeper than that and
there's something that doesn't entail
any parochial religious attachment and
that and so yeah I'm much more focused
on that yeah all right so I I do want to
since I've been spent so much time
around Jordan idea I want to kind of
share some of my thoughts on that
specifically but just to go back a few
minutes I've had a few moments on the
show when I found that if I thinks if
someone's really telling the truth we're
like truly truly locked in and in the
moment that I do feel something I can't
quite explain it I'm sure perhaps you've
had experiences like this when you're
really having a profound moment with
someone that there is a little bit of an
aura like a little bit of something
that's a little bit different and I
actually had it in that moment that you
were talking about that a few moms who
it's a fleeting it's just a bizarre
fleeting thing that I can't quite
explain but I've had it a few times and
it's only happened when I felt that
someone that we were either really
locked in at that level or I thought
someone was truly being as authentic as
they possibly could be so as that was
just happening just then what I really
felt you were saying was be present I
mean almost everything that you just
said really was if we were all
sort of truly being present at the
highest level that we could be which is
virtually impossible to do for more than
a fleeting second and that's a you talk
about that all I'm waking up but that's
how we would achieve I think what you're
looking for is that a fair animation
yeah well so I mean it's hard to do but
it's not it's actually simple it's not
complicated and so they I mean this
circumstance so you and I are having a
conversation we're looking into each
other's eyes this is a this is a
experience that we all have all the time
we're meeting people having these social
encounters is so much of what makes us
human and it's so much of what makes the
sense of self and the sense of self and
other are inextricably bound up and I
you know I would argue that they arise
it's kind of kind of reduced really two
sides of a single coin and so in a
moment like this it's I mean it's just
kind of two levels at which one could be
mindful to use that the the term of
jargon that's now everywhere I mean
mindfulness is just an ability to pay
close attention to what it's like to be
you without grasping at what's pleasant
or pushing away what's unpleasant and
without being lost and thought about it
without without seeing every moment
through this veil of thought so
so unite so the conventional
circumstances you and I are having a
conversation we're looking at one
another and yet we are both can we're
both inundated by our the automaticity
of our own discursive thoughts so you're
talking I'm trying to listen to what
you're saying but I'm being distracted
by my own thinking right so you say
something and I think okay I'm gonna say
what am I gonna say to that yeah and so
that that contest between the contents
of my own mind and just giving you my
attention that's something people are
living with all the time and they if
they're not meditators they only notice
it when things are just when it just
things run completely off the rails so
that you're reading a book and you
realize okay I've read this page three
times and I still don't know what's on
the page like I've just gone down it so
then you're just you're just a
malfunctioning robot
like you just care thinking so much that
you can't pay attention to what you know
you want to pay attention to and but we
have that interpersonally so the first
how real gain would be to be someone who
in a circumstance like this can just
notice the difference between being lost
and thought and really just being
focused on the other person then who's
paying attention and to sort of secure
that in a in a more frequent way by just
get letting go of your thoughts and
coming back and paying attention right
but oddly thinking about that actually
reinforces it in a weird way which is
part of this yeah it's not a matter of
thinking about it's matter of just just
just kind of granting your attention
again and like there's nothing to hold
on to the moment you notice your
thinking you just come back to to pay
attention but the further insight which
you know tends to only come when once
you get pretty good at the first kind of
mindfulness is to notice that this
feeling of being a self over here a
feeling of being behind your face you
know made it so the feeling that you
have that I'm looking at you right the
feeling that I'm looking at something
the feeling that you are there to be
looked at the feeling that you are an
object in the world for me that if you
look for that if you look for yourself
in this moment you can fail to find it
in a way that really does change your
experience like it like it's the sense
of being itself the sense of being the
center of consciousness can drop out in
a way that just just leaves the world
Aegis Li and it it leaves me in the
world but it leaves me it's like lately
there's only one face you see at this
moment you don't see your face you just
see mine and then you know obviously I
I'm in the opposite situation but when
I'm paying attention to you when I'm
really paying attention to you I lose
the sense that I'm over here paying
attention to you I mean there really is
just the world and you're part of it and
that I mean that's the insight that's
often described as emptiness or or the
or selflessness in
in a buddhist context and you can have
that obviously you don't have that in
you don't need another person to have
that you can have that looking at a
coffee cup or even with your eyes closed
but with another person it's really
vivid because so much or so much of our
sense of being a self is ramified by you
being in relationship and i I care what
you think of me or like you you make a
facial expression and I'm reacting like
what does that mean for like how do you
see me it's like we're constantly doing
this dance with one another where we're
reading in the other person's face how
we're doing and that you know that's
something you can have the experience of
just dropping that entirely and it's
it's amazingly freeing to drop that
entirely because you know all of your
psychological suffering and all of your
sense of being imperiled in relationship
to other people is anchored to the sense
of I'm me over here vulnerable to the
thoughts and whims and and and malicious
behavior of others and it's possible to
just cancel that if by paying close
enough attention to what is what
consciousness is like I mean the thing
is the consciousness consciousness
doesn't feel like a self let the feeling
of self is because yet another object in
consciousness it's a say it is it's
something I mean this is again this is
I'm not I'm not making a claim about the
physics of things I'm not this is not
Deepak Chopra saying that the universe
is just consciousness or that we
consciousness was here before the Big
Bang or anything like that but the sense
and I'm not making any claim that
consciousness isn't the product of
brains but subjectively speaking your
sense that consciousness is in your head
is mistaken your head is in
consciousness your the feeling of having
a head the feeling of having a phase all
of that is is appearing in consciousness
in this moment it's just as much in
consciousness as your thoughts are as
the the world is as sounds are I mean so
you're so like the feeling that you're
inside
something is subjectively - it has
things backwards maybe you you can you
can feel vividly that every that
everything in you experience in each
moment is just a matter of consciousness
and its contents and the more you keep
dropping back into that position of just
being the space in which everything is
arising then you can notice that it
doesn't actually feel like what you take
yourself to be in in most moments which
is this this feeling of being a self or
being a a subject you know riding around
in them eat in the middle of everything
appropriating it so I sort of had one of
those moments there yeah I mean I was
trying to do it right in that diary I'm
trying to do it as I'm listening well no
you but you can you can try to do it I
mean you can it's not that that's it's
not that all efforts to do it or doomed
I mean you can you you can learn how to
look for this thing and and then find it
in a way that cancels the sense that
there was anyone looking or and and this
there ways to there broadly speaking
there's are two ways to do this that you
can and again both this is this is what
meditation is they're different styles
of meditation but but they're really
only two ways to do this you can either
look for the self you think you have in
a disciplined enough way and a clear
enough way in a way where you're not
you're you're no longer lost in thought
and you can actually pay attention to
something you have enough concentration
to pay attention and you look for
yourself and you've and you in the first
moment of looking you fail to find it in
a way that is shows you that there's
it's not there yet everything else is
still here and the world is still here
the lights are still on that's one
method another method is to pay close
enough attention to anything else I mean
whether it's a sound or your breath or
sights or another person and recognize
that when you're truly paying
undistracted attention you in that
moment of seeing say a coffee cup there
really is just scene there's not a seer
and the things seen there's not that
you know cuz I mean that really is what
it's like to be continually tiling the
world with concepts you're just you're
just you know it's a it is a kind of
undercurrent of thought in each moment
that you're identified with and not
noticing so if so a lot of techniques of
meditation are just paying such
scrupulous attention to an object a
seeming object that you eventually
collapse the distance between subject
and object and that's it has a more
conventional approach of mindfulness so
I gotta tell you Sam I think getting off
Twitter yeah whole thing thank you well
I really be there all right let's talk
about a little bit of the specifics of
the Jordan because obviously we've done
about 20 of these shows together I can
oh yeah so you've been you've been on a
major tour with him yeah so ed we're you
know I came home now for just like two
or three days and then and then we head
out again uh-huh
you know I think you know that I come
more from a position of a lack of belief
than a position of belief is sort of
where I inherently start probably
similar the way you described yourself
at 18 mm-hmm from every nook he's
different every night every night that
we've done one of these he you know I I
open it up makes people laugh he does
about an hour and a half every single
night it's been different so some nights
he's talking about the fate of the West
some nights he talks about the
sovereignty of the individual some
nights he gives you the twelve rules
that are in the book it says it up every
night but at some point there's always
something that whittles down to
something about truth and belief of
course from what I can I don't want to
as Eric would say if we're gonna do this
we should as Eric ones I would say if
we're gonna do this we should probably
try to steal man him properly and maybe
he'll watch this and I told him that we
were gonna do this so you know hopefully
it offers something for both of you guys
yeah I never see him pushing the
straight-up idea of religion on people
now he is doing the I he's doing it
through the prism that you described the
sort of judeo-christian prism of things
where he's talking about these stories
and what I sense that he's really
hitting on that is resonating with
people and it does resonate with me even
is that the power of these stories and
maybe this is sort of the Joseph
Campbell thing
the power of these stories does offer
some other transcendent truth that you
cannot get another way so the way that I
can give it to you in a way that sort of
makes sense is to me to me is that you
know although I didn't really like the
last couple movies that the amount that
I've loved Star Wars in my life the way
that the stories of Star Wars right that
they those stories of Star Wars have
more relevance to what how I sort of
view good and evil and the journey that
you're on as a person they have more
value to me than anything that I ever
read out of a biblical thing so I'm not
taking his biblical version of it but
that the power of story can somehow
offer you some other some map to truth
that I don't think necessarily is in
conflict with anything you've said does
that no I'm not giving up early what his
argument is I'm just giving you sort of
my personal take yeah no but I'm aware
of what he's been saying in this regard
yeah and and I think this is where maybe
you guys got a little lost in that yeah
that yeah I mean so just as a general
matter I love much of what he says he
does with some regularity say something
ridiculous enough with the same
confidence he says all the good things
that you know I perceive a real problem
give me an example of one of those just
food well I mean did you see his event
with Matt Dillahunty
you see that I didn't see it but I know
yeah that's that's worth watching but so
so and again I'm hoping my hope is that
he we can make progress in these
conversations where we don't get stuck
just having a knock-down drag-out over
over things like the points I'm gonna
raise now because by the way real quick
for the record just I'm more than happy
to tell you like he I think is in that
same exact spot he wanted to be fruitful
and friendly and yeah all of those
things which I think goes back to what
we talked about you know an hour ago
about just yeah the way we all relate to
each other right but I mean he'll
confidently say things like you know
atheists aren't really atheist I mean
like there's a real atheist there's a
psychopath
who murders people me so those people
have existed but someone like Sam Harris
or Richard Dawkins or maybe he said this
directly to Matt Dillahunty in this case
they're not they only think they're a
the--it's not really atheist they have a
God and this function in their life and
then just not acknowledging it right you
know there and again it comes it comes
back to this historical claim that we
all grew up in the West we're all we all
just got our ethics and our our theology
without ever naming it we got it in the
water right and so any sense you have of
what is good and worth doing any sense
you have a value just the reason why it
would be bad to murder somebody
the reason why you don't have to think
that through from first principles every
day and you and you can just navigate
this social space with other people in
the West it's because you are just
fundamentally dependent on these stories
this tradition right and this this God
and he's very you know I don't know what
the steel man interpretation of what
he's actually doing is here but to my
eye he's very you know they're evasive
or non-committal about what he means by
God but he's he's however he's using the
word he's not making a clear claim about
what he believes he'll often say you
know it would take me you know 40 hours
to answer that or I wrote a 600 page
book on that and I can't if I get like
he will do he will decline to answer a
fairly straightforward question but what
he believes about Jesus or about God
right so maybe the bad guys will get
somewhere on that he doesn't I don't
think I think I could probably count on
one hand how many times he's actually
mentioned God specifically in the course
of all this because he but the stories
and the matter what he would say or the
maps of meaning I think I'm much more
important to him than the if to agree on
the exact definition yeah but the but
the claim for instance that I am in a
way that I fundamentally don't
understand but he does mm-hmm that I am
captive of the judeo-christian tradition
right that my ethics is born of it and
that my notion of ultimate value is
somehow anchored to Jesus right
and that is just so preposterous as to
be unarguable right this is Jenny
Shapiro would take a similar argument
just not related to Jesus Jesus though I
think he would say something similar
because my mother was Jewish presumably
he would think I'm you know Jewish
rather than judeo-christian right but
well I that he would say that your
enlightenment values I mean I think when
I've done this with him I would say if I
say well all the goodness in me the
things that I believe in the moral
principles that I believe in are really
enlightenment as he would say well you
really have to dial it back to where
else not proving the point he thinks
he's proving with it right so it's um
but these are the I mean these are like
points of confusion yeah I think we
could get behind it get past in five
minutes but it's also possible that he's
going to dig in for two hours on this
and then we'll have three more events to
do and I'm not sure what the hell is
gonna happen so but I really hope to
make progress with him because again I
think I think what he's doing is very
interesting on on other fronts and what
he's exposed is a real need a real
hunger for a meaning based conversation
about you know you know how do you get
your life straight in a you know in the
21st century and I mean it clearly
clearly there's a hunger for wisdom that
the secular community has not been
answering we in any kind of reliable way
and so when I hear from people who are
saying well you know I mean I've been an
atheist but you know I'm what I'm
hearing from Peterson is you know really
causing me to get my life together that
just tells me that I mean there's no
surprise I've said this about atheism
faith atheism is not a philosophy a
theism is nothing mm-hmm atheism is just
a denial of the the false certainties of
religious people it's like no there's no
there's no good reason to believe in
Poseidon and there's no good reason to
believe in Yahweh that's atheism all
right
so atheism doesn't give you anything
that makes you live a meaningful life
and that's not but the thing is a contra
Petersen that's not a knock on atheism
that's all the atheism atheism is just
not being convinced by the the bad
really the bad evidence and arguments
put forward by religious people it
leaves just a space for better
conversations that you may or may not
have you may or may not discover you may
or may not fall in love with science and
and a rational approach to the
contemplative life so as a we in a weird
way as someone that wants to connect
atheism to spirituality the failure of
whatever the atheist movement before you
was in a weird ways is kind of good
because you you want to lead atheism to
a future right I'm completely
unconcerned by atheism I'm concerned
about the future right right it's like
you know but the again that the place
where Peterson and I will will have
disagreed and will disagree is we I
think he I don't think he understands
atheism or I've never heard him say
anything that that is an accurate
portrayal of what it's like to be you
know this sort of atheist or Nuria and
certainly many atheists I know sort of
reframing your experience yes you but
you but the truth is you can do that
with stories that you know to be
[ __ ]
like you you can do that with Batman
well I'm telling you I know star would
rise in a true story no it has no but
I'm a buddy but you could decide like
I'm gonna I'm gonna get up each morning
and think of myself as Luke Skywalker
like you know you're not Luke Skywalker
well you know Luke Skywalker was
invented by someone who in your lifetime
right so there's no deep thing going
back to our DNA right this is just Luke
Skywalker and you can do it and and
perhaps you know perhaps Jordan would
want to say well known Luke Skywalker
does go back to the DNA because Joseph
Campbell was really in touch with these
ancient myths and was Joseph Campbell
who gave George Lucas all of his you
know story structure okay leave it aside
you could do it with that you pick the
most preposterous character you want
they could still conceivably be
inspiring you know spider-man
right you could get up tomorrow and say
I'm you know I'm just gonna view each
situation Maday that I encounter through
the lens of what would Spider Man do you
know what how would Spider Man act here
how I'm walking into a Starbucks right I
feel sort of vaguely neurotic right I'm
about to meet the barista and I'm like
you know
having trouble making eye contact right
I'm that I'm the same neurotic person I
was yesterday
but how would spider-man do this like
and how would how would you know if I
knew that I could just to take down
everyone in this place if I wanted to
and I can shoot a web and fly over a
building right if I knew that about
myself how would I navigate each
subsequent moment here that the truth
the truth of the matter is that changes
your psychology you can do it with total
fictitious [ __ ] right it's a trick
it's it's a mind hack right that's the
same game right
it doesn't require and and it doesn't
require young to be right about the
collective unconscious now you could say
well it only works if there really is
something that the you know the
substrate layer that is ancient and and
spooky yet that's an empirical claim
that you know maybe unfalsifiable or
maybe worth debating but the reality is
is that stories have power even if you
you and some stories have more power
than others right and we can talk about
you know how why what makes a certain
story more compelling or structured in a
way that it's more compelling but the
reality is that the mind is is plastic
to a remarkable degree and our
persistence in having the same mediocre
mediocre experience we had yesterday is
is a kind of habit mm-hmm and it you can
create other habits that are more
inspiring and more more useful and yes
it is totally possible to use some
traditional framework to do that or some
weird cultic framework I mean someone
can invent a new you know a new
operating system and you don't call it
Scientology or call it whatever and
gather acolytes under that in that
context and even the yeah and this is
how weird our circumstance is you can
have a malicious fraud doing that
someone like l ron hubbard who's just
clearly a conman right and people can
derive genuine benefit from it it's not
like every Scientologist is wrong about
the benefit they got from science
it's clearly they're not right it
wouldn't wouldn't persist to the degree
that it has if everyone's just having a
bad time and seeing no benefit ever
right it's not it's not it would be over
in a day well they're sweating on all
that whatever they're doing in the sauna
so all right so then that I think maybe
we can wrap with that yeah I don't want
to I'm not here to litigate obviously on
behalf of door tonight I thought it'd
have to just get some of these ideas and
sure we'll get into house but what's the
date of the first one people would have
my website Alliance or no the first it's
the end of this month in Vancouver we've
got two shows right the 23rd and forth
yeah and then we've got Dublin in London
in July middle of July 14th
I think it's Dublin and the 16th is
London could be a day off there well I
have him back in here on the 29th
that'll be right in between the two so
maybe that'll be an interesting so hot
yeah I know it was actually breathe yeah
yeah all right so then my final thing on
this and then we can wrap would be so
what does it matter at the end of the
day let's say let's say everything
you've said here is true and and a
certain amount of people watching this
can can start going down that road and
finding truth that allows them to live
as presently and honestly and and
fulfilling ly as possible and let's say
for the amount of people that are
showing up to Jordans events they hear
what he's saying and feel that it allows
them to do that exact same thing whether
you believe that that's skimming off the
top or not fully actualized up but but
they ultimately live a good life that is
you know that the life that's coming
from what you're prescribing to what
George prescribed ultimately both become
comparably moral decent good lives at
the end of the day then does it matter
well I think having a coherent idea
about truth matters and so this is a
sticking point that Jordan and I hit in
our first podcast and I see it operating
in a lot of what he's saying and so that
I think should be ironed out and I think
it can be ironed out and you can still
be totally enamored of the usefulness of
myth
like you can still like almost nothing
else shifts in what he's doing and you
can still acknowledge that there's a
difference between this is what Brett
Weinstein and I think usefully dubbed
metaphorical truth and the literal truth
and it's only by the light of literal
truth that you can even make that
distinction right like like clearly we
need that those two categories and we
need to be able to say that certain
things are not literally true but
they're useful right and certain things
are just starkly false I mean they don't
even have to have no truth to them and
if someone could just be miss
fundamentally mistaken about reality and
that could be their certain status the
circumstances under their circumstances
under which that could be useful right
so it's like like likely to make those
distinctions is the only way to preserve
a notion of truth that gets you
something like a legitimate science and
legitimate error correcting mechanism
where it really matters that your
beliefs both be internally consistent or
belief system being internally
consistent and map on to reality in some
way that is you know if they were false
you would be unlikely to believe what
you believe I mean that but the problem
is what people are getting and this is
you know traditionally what religion has
been and what what dogmatism always
gives you
I mean dogmatism is the state of no
longer interacting with reality in a way
that would that would error correct your
beliefs like I'm gonna believe this
thing that I believed yesterday no
matter what you tell me no matter what
you show me no matter what happens in
human history Jesus is the Son of God
right whatever whatever it is right
that's that's religion it traditionally
speaking and that is precisely the state
in which the human mind and human
communities can't error correct and make
intellectual progress so clearly that's
not that part is not worth preserving
and to some degree I perceive Jordan is
trying to have it both ways and he'll
he'll he'll endorse science you know in
you know various ways but he will also
endure
and he won't call it dogmatism but I'm
perceiving it to be dogmatism and so
that's something that I certainly hope
that we can flesh out and verge on so
it's good that you guys are doing four
of these because ya know each one is
going to sort of be like a discovery
session until yeah until you can get
enough of an agreement on that sort of
base level stuff and yeah you may end up
just lost in the weeds on it well we
haven't we unlike my podcast we have a
moderator really in all four times right
the Brett Weinstein is actually a
moderator for Vancouver so he knows his
job and and I think he'll be great at it
Douglas Murray is joining us in London
and Dublin and he's not a moderator but
I think just just having Douglas there
will keep us from from missing each
other totally I mean they'd ugly so
that's a very calming effect yeah yeah
all right well I don't think we should
go two years again before no yeah before
we do this again we have we should also
say we have a conference coming up in
know in New York and in November which
you are are M seen yeah and this is
actually this is this is very cool this
is sort of an idea you've been bouncing
around for yeah because this is a rather
than avoid controversial topics for this
this conference we decided to just just
rams toward that the most provocative
and so we have a session on me too
well I think it's titled has me to gone
too far and it's gonna be a panel of
women all women journalists I think
that's true to say in fantastic people
like Masha Gessen
and Barry Weiss and Katie Roy Effie
Rebecca tracer I don't think can make it
but so but it the we're still building
it out but it's it's it will be the full
spectrum of yes it's gone too far to it
hasn't gone far enough thread so it
should be a very interesting
conversation there's a panel on race
with Glenn Lowry who you know is
fantastic and I'm pretty sure we're done
hasta Coates it's going to do it and so
Tommy it's just as far to the yeah
the extreme racialist side of this as
possible so and then and you just wanted
to thrust me in the middle of this thing
and see what happens
anyway I wish you all have to talk about
how that stuff gets moderated but and
then it's got Coleman Hughes this yes
young crazy undergraduate who's writing
these these pieces in Colette to give
you a sense of just how weird the the
the left is so so Coleman Hughes has
written these these pieces on race and
Colette he's this African American
undergraduate at Columbia writing these
essays that that so many of us have
found just just one incredibly
well-written write images he does not
have any of the the affectations if
someone who's over writing at his age
which is just amazingly rare yeah yeah
and just so clear-headed
right and and so i retweeted one of his
essays saying like you know
congratulations Coleman and I just
decided to check my ad mentions just
just but not just to take the
temperature of the situation and this is
more evidence of my racism that I'm that
I'm favorably retweeting it's like like
this this Uncle Tom you know as you
expect so it's amazing but anyway that
again will be a panel that spans the
full range of opinion on these topic on
this topic of race the question is can
we get beyond race and then there's a
panel on Islam that will have Mudgett
and I on who you know are all stars on
the you know I would argue the perfectly
sane side of this conversation but it
will also have Fareed Zakaria and and
shadi Hameed who you know I view it was
the kind of intervention on those guys
because like they're into my ear they've
just been making the wrong noises on
this and I did I've done the podcast
with both of them but me being a white
guy non-muslim you know who didn't grow
up in the culture there's there's
there's certain moves not open to me for
you know the kind of audience that will
be persuaded by you know someone like
Fareed or shot a saying you don't
understand the Muslim experience or
whatever it is so obviously they can't
do that talking to a on
and Majin coursera hater and so all of
those people will be on the panel and
that that should be fascinating and then
finally there's a panel that Fareed is
actually going to go to moderate which
is a truth is I'm on it I don't know who
else is gonna be on I think it's gonna
be Eric Weinstein and Brett Weinstein
and a few other people and they'll just
be talking about rationality and it is
reason sacred as the title of that panel
and you're doing a meditation session oh
yeah I think I'm gonna do a meditation
workshop in that so it's like a 10-hour
day but I didn't get a good
after all this moderation I'm gonna need
a little yeah so I were to come by for
that and Center for that one okay all
right well it's always a pleasure my
friend but don't follow him on Twitter
because there's no I won't be happening
there but you can check out the waking
up podcast at sam harris org
[Music]